hi this is pressure Locker this math
problem is being shared around Facebook
and one of the recent post has over two
million comments I've seen this post
being shared since December but for some
reason it's getting really popular right
now and the means through media is
talking about how this problem is
baffling the Internet
so I wanted to address the problem in
this video and discuss what many people
believe to be the correct answer
can you figure it out so we can consider
this as a math problem if you consider
the Apple the banana and the coconut as
different variables and know having
numerical values we'll start out with
the first equation that three apples are
equal to 30 if we divide both sides by 3
we get the result that one Apple is
equal to 10 this is generally an
accepted part of the problem we'll use
the information the Apple in the second
equation and this is where things get a
little more debatable so the Apple is
equal to 10 and then if you look at the
rest of the equation you have two
different bunches of bananas now some
people consider one whole bunch of
banana as one variable but I would
consider counting each banana separately
so they're actually 4 bananas in each
Bunch
so you'd want to count that there are
1/8 total of 8 different single bananas
and that equals 18 so we subtract by 10
and then divide by 8 we get the result
that each banana is equal to 1 we now
have the equation that for bananas - a
full coconut is equal to 2 so we have 4
- the coconut equals 2 we can solve this
to get that the coconut is equal to 2
now even people who agree up to this
point still might have a debate about
the very last line which is what you're
supposed to evaluate because if you look
closely there's some differences in our
pictures we don't have a full coconut we
actually have a half coconut so the full
coconut is equal to 2 then a half
coconut would be equal to 1 so we have 1
for the coconut we add 10 for the Apple
and finally people still get confused at
this point because we don't have
for bananas if you look closely we
actually only have three bananas so you
want to add three at this point and you
get one plus ten plus three and that
gives us our answer of 14 this is what
most people consider be the correct
answer you could interpret the pictures
to be slightly different you could say
the coconut might be say three-fourths
of the coconut in which case you get a
slightly different answer but 14 is what
many people consider to be the correct
answer thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math and game theory you can
catch around my blog mind your decisions
which you can follow on Facebook Google+
and patreon you can catch me on social
media app brush talker and if you liked
the video please check out my books
their links in the video description